welcome back to another edition of the
gadget lab show i'm michael colauri and
i'm matt honum and matt what is this
lovely device that you have here this is
the microsoft surface rt which is uh
microsoft's
new tablet uh you reviewed this for us
on wired.com very good very uh very long
and balanced review
i did i i it was very long
um
but you liked it i liked it as a device
as a platform i like it a lot it's it's
a it's a great device very solid piece
of hardware uh
it's got this really interesting little
touchpad keyboard or touch cover it's
called that lets you
type on the same thing that
serves as your tablet cover very cool uh
it's also got this backside kickstand so
that you can set it up and
type on it it's got a lot of stuff but
not a lot of programs right so that's
the big question now
microsoft is releasing this this week
and it's available you can buy it you've
been able to pre-order it for a couple
of weeks so people are going to get
these they're going to take them home
open up and then what are they going to
be able to do on them i mean you
mentioned it's
a laptop replacement like it has the
productivity apps you'd expect from a
microsoft product right
it's a very basic laptop replacement
like it's you know you'll be able to
do stuff in office browse the web send
email um but it's it's it's not going to
have the you know kind of power user
specs that you may want or power user
programs that you may want it's not
going to have like it's got an email
client but the email client is kind of
and it's got the big stuff it has
netflix kindle
things like that but not a lot of games
yet not a lot of games not a lot of good
games yet there are a lot of games in
there but there probably aren't a lot
that you're going to want to
play
um well you know i would expect sort of
like a gold rush when this thing first
gets out you know a lot of people are
going to want to get into the app into
their app store what are they calling it
the microsoft microsoft i think it's
called the windows store the windows
store so a lot of people want to get
into the windows store right away start
making apps for these devices
start making money and like stake their
claim um but
it's still still going to suffer from
the volume problem are they going to
sell enough of these where
people who aren't part of that initial
rush are going to want to
go there and develop something to run on
it to make it more useful
it definitely has this chicken and egg
problem you know i mean people aren't
going to buy it right away because it's
not going to have tons of apps like the
ipad does
and people
are you know app developers aren't
necessarily going to develop for it
because there aren't a ton of customers
yet but something to keep in mind is
that
you can write an app for the windows
store that will run on a lot of devices
other than just the surface it's not uh
it's not quite like the ipad in that
there's only one device because anybody
who's a windows manufacturer can put out
you know versions of windows rt versus
windows 8 that you can also sell your
apps in the windows store and get those
customers as well so i might have a you
know a
an hp or a lenovo device that could also
run an app it doesn't have to be the
surface and there are there is literally
a flood
of
windows rt hardware coming down the pipe
right now i think so yeah i mean i think
i think i i think the technical term for
it is a dump truck load
a dump truck load
so
do do you think that it still makes a
sensible purchase if somebody's
considering a tablet
a sensible purchase uh instead of an
ipad from an app perspective purely from
an app perspective purely from an app
perspective
it doesn't come close to the ipad you
know there's a uh
if you're looking at it just from from
am i going to be able to go in and find
basically every app that i can think of
and and you know play great games
have you know all kinds of
weird add-ons that let me do interesting
things no it doesn't have that and and
it's probably not going to have that for
a while you know i'm talking at least
months and who knows
and
you know if
the way i look at this is this is very
much a you know a new platform and it
already does some very cool things like
it already does this really interesting
hybrid thing of letting you
type on it i mean it's built for typing
you can use a bluetooth keyboard with an
ipad but i've never found it totally
satisfying what it doesn't do is do all
that extra fun stuff with apps that
ipads do
okay
well thank you for bringing by the
device and showing it to us and by the
way you can read matt's full review and
watch his video review on wired.com
reviews and you can continue to read
coverage of
windows rt and the surface tablet and
all things microsoft on gadget lab and
now
we're going to bring on robbie
to talk about e-readers
yay robbie
roberto baldwin is here
hi hi and you've brought some uh fancy
new e-readers i did bring some fancy new
e-readers let's start with the first one
which is
the kobo glow this is kobo's answer to
the nook simple touch with glow light
and the kindle paper white it has a
glowing screen which is actually really
really nice that's very cool all right
um the
yeah it's a really nice glow screen and
uh the the contrast on this screen is
actually really good too so um i'm
working on a review right now this and
i'm i'm impressed so far that's cool and
actually my favorite thing about that
before you put it away is that um you
know there's this thing on e-readers
called like garbage collection or full
screen refresh that you if the screen
looks kind of dull and then you flip
through a few pages and all of a sudden
you get a screen that's super clear it
doesn't actually fully refresh the
screen until every you know five or six
or seven
screen refreshes this lets you select so
if it's really bothering you you can
have it you can have it refresh the
screen every page flip or one to six
page flip so you can do like three pages
four pages five pages one page um
the kindle the paperwhite lets you do
every page if you want you can set it
that way yeah but this will let you set
that if you know you're seeing a lot of
artifacts or something i haven't seen
any
issues with it but it that that level of
uh
of uh
you know enhancement to your reading is
pretty awesome yeah and i think it's
great that that's becoming a standard
because that's people's biggest
complaint about e-readers is oh the
screen's kind of
but you know if you get the opportunity
to refresh it every page if you want if
you're that kind of person then now you
have it finally so i think it's been a
long time coming bam that's a props to
kobo for that one
coba also has something that i got
really excited about i'm not really
excited about the ipad mini because i'm
not really excited about tablets in
general
personally i mean and you know for
people out in the world who love tablets
yay
but i got excited about this this showed
up it's the kobo mini it's a teeny tiny
little e-reader it's really small it's
really it's so cute i i i squealed when
i saw it i didn't squeal but i went
woohoo which is like a dude squeal i
think
this one does not light up it does not
light up it is a touch screen you can
you know back and forth and how much
does that cost compared to the bigger
one this is 89. okay um
i can't remember the price of that one
oh
okay it'll be in the review it'll be in
the review so 89 is a lot to spend uh
you can spend like 10 15 bucks less than
that and get a kindle with buttons
yeah you can get the kindle uh just a
regular old 69 kindle with buttons and
uh but with ads if you hate ads well
what if i want to spend maybe like 20
bucks on an e-reader if you want to
spend 20 bucks on the e-reader we have
the texter this is a country out of
germany beagle
it's a country out of germany it's a
country out of germany called germany
it's an e-reader out of germany um this
company texter
they have this e-reader and you can't
actually just buy this e-reader it's
actually pretty impressive for you know
something that's under 20 bucks
um
that's just crazy yeah it's they're
they're saying that they're they're
wanting to uh add it as far as
subsidized smartphone sales so you could
get it for like 13 bucks in addition to
buying your iphone um from att verizon
sprint whoever you buy your smartphones
from
so i buy a smartphone and then it comes
with for an extra fee like headphones
and this and this thing yeah
what if i just want the e-reader what if
i already have they they don't have a
price yet for just the e-reader okay
they are very they they really want to
sell this with smartphones because
it doesn't have wi-fi
like you can't get online with it all it
does is read it has bluetooth and you
sync it with a with right now with an
android phone but eventually with an
android and ios phone and you download
the books on your smartphone and then
you sync them over here that's very cool
but it runs on two
aaa batteries and it'll last 10 to 15
bucks wow which they figure is about a
year that's about a year it's it's kind
of cool i like the little the little
thing yeah for the battery it's a nice
it's actually it's it's a great little
natural handle yeah it's only got three
buttons forward back and home
that's it it's very cool the texture
beagle so hopefully we'll see this uh
for sale as a standalone device but
until then um when do they think it's
going to hit the u.s market they're
still uh trying to iron out you know
they're in talks everyone's always in
talks with people but it's uh we got one
and um yeah i was pleasantly surprised
very cool very cool well thank you for
the fancy german e-reader and the fancy
canadian e-readers kobo's canadian
company thank you uh international day
here on the podcast
and uh robbie's gonna have reviews of
all this stuff which you can read at
wired.com and until then we'll see you
next time on the catcher lab